- Listen to that?
(siren)
- Yeah, there's some
crime happening,
there's definitely
some crime happening,
but it's not in our area,
so we're not required
to respond to the call.
Next time use the walk.
- crosswalk.
- The crosswalk.
- Yeah, yeah next time you
use the crosswalk, okay.
- I didn't mean an
actual wok, I didn't mean
like a pan, I didn't
want that to be like a
racial stereotype.
- I heard wok vegetables.
- Alright.
- Chinese wok.
- So, next time I won't
say walk, I'll say,
"stay between the parallel
white lines, oriental woman."
- That's much better.
(upbeat music)
- Yeah, you got a guy over there
in the bushes taking a (bleep).
Sir, are you okay tonight?
- Yeah, are you doing alright?
- Yes sir.
- Okay.
- Stay cool.
Let us know if you
need any TP, okay?
- I will.
(police radio)
- You wanna roll
down the window?
How you doin'?
- It's good.
- Okay, and make sure
we use a condom, right,
and enjoy yourself.
- I think she was giving
him a handjob at the light.
- Hand-Doogie.
- It's not a handjob,
it's a hand adventure.
(mouthed war sound effects)
Sir, excuse me, sir.
- This guy's a
real dance machine.
Look at this guy, he
might not be human.
- He's been playing a lot
of dance dance revolution
I take it.
This is a cell phone free
corner, you wanna fold that up,
put it in your pocket
and get on your way.
Sir, you got any dope on you?
No, nothing.
- Do us a favor and
just keep it moving.
- I see you still standing here.
We know that when we get to
the other side of this tunnel,
it's a part of the city
that's frequented by
the street ninja.
- Ooh, what's that!?
- Street ninja.
(slow techno music)
Look alive, the weird
thing is just back here.
(mouthed siren sound effect)
- When you see
something like Musey...
- Takes my breath away.
- That's right.
- I love it.
- It's as though what Musey
is missing between his legs,
is punching Officer
John right in the chest.
- Augh!
- Sir, you have one too many
bags for this jurisdiction.
Thumbs up to you.
- There she is, every night
we like to come by here,
and watch out favorite lady
work out on her elliptical.
- She's slowing down,
she must be going up
a digital hill.
- Look at her.
- Get outta my car, now!
- Jesus christ.
- Get out, get out!
- Alright, alright.
- You really think this is
alright, you go into my room
and you take my police
officer uniforms and
the two of you put 'em on,
and you start driving
around in my car,
that Ma sold me, not you, me!
You know, get these hats,
okay, take the shirts off now,
take 'em off.
You took that outta my
(bleep) laundry pile.
You and you, never again
will you be seen in my car.
- We like the bus anyway.
- You know what get the
(bleep), shut the (bleep) up,
gimme that (bleep) thing.
Never again!
- You gotta, it's locked.
- Don't tell me
about my (bleep) car!
- We love you, John.
- Eat (bleep) and
die, you (bleep).
- Yeah, we're gonna need backup.
- We can walk it.
- I'd rather get
picked up if we can.
(police radio)
- Hi everybody, thanks
for watching out videos,
we hope you enjoy them as
much as our mother does,
and if you enjoy the videos,
please leave a comment or...
- Watch the other videos.
- Rewatch, hit the like
button, we appreciate that.
- Go enjoy the day.
- It makes us feel real nice.
Or, leave a nasty message,
we enjoy that, too.